tous et à toutes d'être présent ce soir
donc ceci est la troisième édition du
séminaire énergie climat développement
de l'afd agence française de
développement
alors les séances précédentes nous
avions dû première séance alain
grandjean en deuxième séance
hervé le treut tu es puis en troisième
nous avons maintenant aujourd'hui la
joie est davantage d'accueillir jean
marc jancovici
alors il ya une unité profonde dans ses
différents orateurs puisque jean marc et
alain se connaissent bien puisqu'ils
sont tous les deux codirecteurs
cofondateur de société carbone 4 qui est
la société de conseil sur le carbone
l'énergie le climat en france
comme vous le savez tous et toutes et
jean marc est également le président du
think tank de shift produit le tsb
jean-marc à contribuer au débat national
sur la transition comité d expiration
débat national
la transition qui était présidée par
alain et donc deux compères étaient déjà
présentes sur ce terrain là et je
remarque que vous savez est très présent
sur la question des débats sur la
transition énergétique différents mix
énergétique que nous pourrions choisir
ensemble collectivement pour la france à
l'horizon et 10 ans en 2035 avec des
positions que vous avez certainement
découvrir voilà le thème de ce soir
c'est pas grave
voilà le thème de 6 à 15 ans et demi à
thierry d'accord 21 la coop 21 et on n'a
pas donné plus de contraintes et un
j'embarque cinq fois son service
cette question voilà le temps qu'on
installe des slides sur l'ordinateur qui
est compatible avec vidéoprojecteur donc
l'arrivée du jeu c'est jean marc tu nous
parles 45 minutes
et puis ensuite on pourra interagir avec
vous posez toutes les questions vous
aviez envie de poser un journal depuis
toujours et que vous n'avez pas encore
eu l'occasion de poser c'est le moment
pour le faire tout à l'heure après
l'exposé de 45 minutes on arrête
onze centres aux blazers
c'est là
je
et 1
voilà le
c'est pas ça c'est possible
bonsoir à toutes et à tous
1 donc effectivement la question qui
avait été posé mais comme l'a fortement
juste fait enfants justement un candidat
elle là la réponse raisonnablement
indépendante de la question comme dans
toute bonne interview politique
je vais essayer de vous raconter trois
choses sur ce qu'on peut tirer comme
bilan de la coop 21
sachant que comme certains d'entre vous
l'ont peut être vu et lu dans la presse
un certain nombre de commentaires ont
donné l'impression que cet événement
avait séparé l'ombre de la lumière c'est
à dire qu'avant il y avait un amant qui
savaient pas où ils allaient peu après
il ya un monde qui a enfin une voie
tracée et un problème qui est déjà à
87,2 % résolu et je vais essayer de vous
montrer que c'est hélas un peu plus
compliqué que ça je vais faire un petit
rappel lors je suis désolé je sait
jamais quel est le pourcentage des gens
dans la salle qui sont déjà reliés à la
baisse trois fois donc je vais quand
même démarré par le commencement
je vais vous rappeler un tout petit peu
pourquoi est ce que il ya un tout petit
sujet quand on s'occupe de limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
pourquoi c'est pas un truc qu'on fait là
claquement de doigts certains d'entre
vous sont peut être suffisamment vieux
pour se souvenir du problème des gaz
fluorés et du trou dans la couche
d'ozone qui est pas introduit par une
couche soit dit en passant est le on
s'est mis autour d'une table on a fait
un gentil protocole qui s'appelait
montréal et on a réglé le problème
alors en ce qui concerne les gaz à effet
de serre c'est un peu plus compliqué que
ça parce que montréal c'était un
protocole qui concernait un problème
qu'on pouvait traiter toutes choses
égales par ailleurs c'est à dire qu'on a
pris un problème qui était
raisonnablement détachable d'à peu près
tout ce qu'on faisait par ailleurs on a
vu les gens dans un coin
il était de bonne volonté le protocole
permettait aux gros de tuer les petits
dont tout le monde était content et le
truc a pu être signés lors ce qui
concerne les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre le problème est un peu plus
complexe que ça parce que c'est
intimement lié à ce qui fait la corne
d'abondance qui vous permet de devenir
dans cette salle
à cette heure ci et non pas d'être
occupés à
stocker les pataquès que vous avez
cultivés à la sueur de votre front
pendant la journée
c'est à dire l'énergie à profusion alors
si je suis un tout petit peu plus
explicatif mère-nature en quelques
dizaines à quelques centaines de
millions d'années nous a fourni des
combustibles fossiles qui sont des
résidus de vie ancienne à vous savez les
combustibles fossiles c'est des fossiles
de dictionnaires était bien fait sur ce
plan
donc le charbon cdrs de fougères le
pétrole et le gaz sont des restes de
micro algues et de plancton et ça a été
formée grâce à la vie ancienne la
tectonique des plaques et la chaleur
interne de la terre et c'est
parfaitement gratuit alors là je vais
commencer à prendre un gros boost point
le premier truc que vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu dans la vulgate écologique
classique qui est le vent et le soleil
sont gratuits ce qui est tout à fait
vrai la formation du vent à la formation
du soleil c'est parfaitement gratuit
formation du pétrole du gaz et du
charbon est tout aussi gratuite personne
dans cette salle la payer le moindre
centime pour que se forment les énergies
que je viens de décrire
c'est je le répète une petite fraction
des 14 milliards d'années qui nous
séparent de dublin qui vous avis ça à
disposition totalement gratuitement donc
ce que coûte le pétrole le gaz et le
charbon c'est la sueur de notre front
pour aller chercher point barre ça ne
coûte rien d'autres anciens candidats
soir de notre front si aussi
consentement à s'en défaire pour celui
qui a la bonne idée d'être assis dessus
mais ça n'est que des revenus d'accords
l'énergie pour l'extraire de
l'environnement vous ne payez que des
revenus humains l'énergie m elle est
gratuite quelle que soit l'énergie
le dictionnaire étant toujours bien fait
les combustibles brûle et cette
combustion nous a donné les moteurs et
la chimie et les moteurs et la chimie
nous ont permis d'augmenter par un
facteur de quelques centaines
la puissance d'action de nos carcasse de
nos muscles sur l'environnement et nous
ont ainsi permis de transformer encore
une fois avec un facteur multiplicatif
absolument hallucinant toutes les autres
sources tout aussi gratuites soit dit en
passant que mère nature a mis à notre
disposition en 14 milliards d'années
d'évolution depuis le big bang et donc
nous avons transformé à vitesse
accélérée des pierres de carrière des
arêtes de poisson du bois etc
en fait toujours du minerai de fer tout
ce qu'on a tout ce qui nous est tombé
sous la main pour en faire toujours à
vitesse accélérée tout un tas de trucs
sympathiques comme les câbles vga et
moins sympathiques comme les câbles hd
pardon grâce à cette profusion matériel
nous avons construit un système socio
économique unique et totalement anormal
au sens étymologique du terme c'est à
dire en dehors de la normale par rapport
à ce qu'a été les conditions de vie ou
ce qu'on était les conditions de vie
dans notre espèce depuis qu'on les
sédentariser savait que notre espèce
existe en gros il peut le manteau locks
sécher un peu enfin depuis sans vie dans
3 millions d'ha les surmonte à lui si on
est sédentarisées depuis à peu près dix
mille ans nous sommes soit dit en
passant sédentarisés grâce à la
remarquable stabilité du système
climatique sur la dernière dizaine de
milliers d'années c'est ça qui fait que
nous avons réussi a cessé d'être nomade
ianu sédentarisés donc c'est grâce à ça
qu'on a des villes et un système
comptable qui nous occupe tant en ce
moment ça donc cette profusion d'objets
matériels nous a donné la structure
socio-économique et a totalement
transformé les métiers c'est à cause de
ça qu'on a 70% des gens dans le
tertiaire c'est à cause de ça que 2 %
d'agriculteurs nous faut manger de la
viande à tous les repas
c'est à cause de ça qu'on a fait les
villes et combien vie tout le monde et
c'est rare et c'est quand vous regardez
la manière dont un pays c'est
physiquement organisé le premier
déterminant que vous allez trouver c'est
son approvisionnement énergétique
tout le reste est un déterminant
secondaire cette contrepartie de la
transformation 16 c en termes
économiques le fameux pib vous savez
quand économique un plein des économies
se distinguer dans cette salle je suis
sûr c'est une manière de conter la
transformation l'énergie aussi est une
manière de conter la transformation
c'est même sa définition en physique
compter l'énergie en physique ses
comptes et la transformation
donc quand vous regardez une
modification de notre spa prenant place
dans notre système productif
vous pouvez toujours raconté de deux
manières différentes avec des euros ou
wade de l'énergie et vous n'avez pas de
roue sans énergie jamais jamais jamais
au pire entre guillemets c'est l'énergie
nos muscles vous n'avez pas de
transformation sans énergie alors cette
fête perpétuelle aujourd'hui buts sur
deux limites
une première dont on va parler ce soir
très médiatisé très connu qui l a
contrainte aval du système
je mets dans l'atmosphère des gaz dire
effet de serre alors qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un gaz à effet de serre en termes
strictement scientifique c'est un gaz
qui présente des raies d'absorption dans
l'infrarouge émis par la terre ne sera
gaz à effet de serre
c'est une définition scientifique très
précises
leur existence est connue depuis un
siècle et demi il ya un siècle et demi
il n'y avait pas de climato sceptiques
parce qu'il n'y avait aucun enjeu avec
climato sceptiques
il ya des climato sceptiques depuis que
cela contrarie les envies ou les ego de
quelques-uns que le changement
climatique soit une réalité
mais on ne devient pas climato
sceptiques parce que la science est
devenu fausse la science qui est à la
base de cette affaire très très vieille
fourier le premier à identifier le fait
qu'ils avaient un effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère ça date d'il ya deux
siècles les gaz à effet de serre
principaux il est identifié il ya un
siècle et demi il ya plus d'un siècle
karen us a fait le bon calcul d'ordre de
grandeur sur ce qu'on est en droit
d'attendre sur le système climatique
d'un doublement du co2 dans l'atmosphère
la science est très vieille ce qui est
très récent c'est de comprendre que ça
peut contrarier les envies ou les goûts
d'un certain nombre y compris du
consommateur que ce soit une réalité
le changement climatique très médiatisée
parce que toute la production est sur la
table c'est les chercheurs qui
travaillent le chercheur
gaye le sait bien son métier c'est de
rendre public ce qu'il sait encore jeudi
rendu publiques ça veut pas dire que
l'on comprend ça veut dire que tout est
à disposition des tiers
parce que c'est grâce à ça qu'il est
reconnu on a un autre sujet qui lui est
beaucoup moins médiatisé mais qui est
déjà à l'oeuvre de manière très dures en
europe depuis 2007 et qui s'appelle la
contrainte
ah non c'est à dire que pour alimenter
le système est bien il faut en quantité
croissante des flux en provenance des
réservoirs d'énergie à farrou des
gisements d'énergies fossiles problème
non médiatisé parce que pour avoir une
vue un peu synthétique de ce problème il
faut aller questionner un par un les
gens qui en ont un petit morceau et qui
n'ont aucune envie aucun intérêt à
mettre sur la place publique ce qu'ils
servent n'existe pas d'obligation de
fournir un inventaire mondial des
ressources en énergies fossiles alors
que je le redis un chercheur son intérêt
c'est de publier ce qu'il sait or les
deux problèmes c'est par là que je
finirais cette intervention sont en
train de s'exprimer sur les mêmes
échelles de temps donc en fait on va
devoir régler le problème aval du
changement climatique
en même temps que se renforcent le
problème amont c'est à dire que la
croissance vous pouvez l'oublier dans
les pays occidentaux de manière
croissante
pardon pour le genou donc la croissance
c'est déjà une affaire du passé en
europe déjà une affaire du passé au
japon et ça sera dans pas très longtemps
une affaire du passé aux états unis
et c'est dans ce cadre là qu'on va
devoir gérer le problème aval voilages
insiste un peu là dessus parce qu'encore
une fois le problème aval très
médiatisée parce que là
pierre première est par essence public
le problème en ont très peu médiatisé
parce que la matière première est par
essence détenus par des opérateurs
privés
voilà à quoi sert aujourd'hui l'énergie
ça sert à faire des esclaves des temps
modernes
donc vous avez ici à tout petit ridicule
sous-échantillon et dont une fois qu'on
les a dotés de leur nourriture
particulière qui soit dit en passant a
l'énorme avantage de venir du sous sol
et non pas du sol donc aux esclaves des
temps modernes mange du sous sol et ne
mange pas du sol
donc il avait toute la surface
disponible pour nous je vous rappelle
que c'est le charbon tient à sauver les
forêts en europe donc le sous sol sol
sol tant qu'il n'a pas d'inconvénient
majeur
et bien c'est ces machines des temps
modernes qui fournissent aux terriens
ordinaires y compris les indiens et
pakistanais et les habitants du zimbabwe
en moyenne 1 l'équivalent de 200
esclaves par personne et aux smicards
français l'équivalent de quatre à cinq
cents c'est l'énergie alimentant des
esclaves mécanique très beau cela secoue
de savoir s'ils ont droit si l'on me il
faut les maintenir en vie qui nous
rendent les services mais content dé
multiplier de manière absolument
faramineuses grâce à l'énergie que nous
rendait dans les temps anciens les
esclaves humains comme on en n'avait
hélas propre carcasse quand on en avait
pas vous comprenez dès à présent c'est
pas très sympa l'idée de renoncer à
cette belle fête perpétuelle et que s'il
faut renoncer à écouter des
conférenciers illuminé tard le soir pour
aller re commencé à stocker des patates
dans une cave bien il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui nous dira budget
moyen en vie quoi quand même voici la
traduction de ce que je viens de vous
raconter avec quelques petites côtes
sympathique ici vous avez une courbe
alors donc je vous le rappelle c'est à
cause de l'énergie que l'on peut
transformer donc on a de la production
industrielle est derrière du pib et en
voici une courbe qui est la traduction
directe de ce que je viens de dire ils
devront faire du facteur 200 à l'échelle
mondiale j'évite en abscisse sur cette
courbe la quantité d'énergie consommée
dans le monde et j'ai vu en ordonnée sur
cette courbe le produit industriel
mondial en dollars constants depuis 1970
eh bien vous cassez pas la tête
regardez l'énergie vous avez l'industrie
simplicité absolument biblique
je vous fait grâce parce que c'est pas
le sujet ce soir de ce que ça donne pour
l'europe mais en gros vous avez un point
de rebroussement en 2007 donc ça monte
vers le haut à droite en 2007 qui à
partir de 2007 ça recommence à descendre
de l'autre côté même motif même punition
donc ça c'est une petite taquineries
pour gaël vous avez ici le meilleur
modèle macroéconomique du monde
j'avais une droite prenez l'énergie vous
avez privé pas besoin de faire d
équation compliquée machin tout ne
marche pas très bien
c'est à cause du reste de ce lien
énergie pib que le meilleur signe avant
coureur de ce que sera le pib c'est
l'approvisionnement énergétique et donc
c'est à cause de ça que je peux vous
dire sans aucun risque de me tromper
j'ai déjà fait trois fois sans se
tromper que nous sommes à la veille
d'une nouvelle crise économique
significative parce que
l'approvisionnement économique dans les
pays de ces lieux est orienté à la
baisse et qu'il a continué de baisser il
va en fait compte d'essai à vitesse
accélérée avec les prix du pétrole qu'on
constate actuellement et donc on va de
nouveau avoir quelque chose de très
significatif dans le système économique
après vous demandez pas si ça va être la
belle chinoise le crédit immobilier aux
états unis où la faillite ddm jean-luc
autrement aucune idée par contre la
probabilité qu'ils ne se passe rien de
significatif dans les pays de l' ocde
dans les deux ans qui viennent me paraît
extrêmement faibles suffisamment faible
auquel je sois prêt à paris une partie
de mes propres économies avec une partie
d'entre nous voilà un dernier lien de
cause à une dernière analyse statistique
qui vient appuyer ce que je vous ai
raconté lorsque je suis en train de lire
la cepal preuve ce n'est pas parce que
c'est correct c'est une preuve c'est
parce que j'ai mon rapport de un à 500
entre la puissance moyenne des hommes et
la puissance moyenne du parc de machines
en occident que le pib reflète
l'approvisionnement énergétique est
alors ici c'est pas le pib que je suis
en train de regarder c'est sa variation
lâchant 5 comparé les dérivés est ce que
vous voyez c'est que si je prends la
variation de l'approvisionnement
énergétique dans le monde que vous avez
ici en bleu eh bien je suis à peu près
en train de regarder la variation du pib
dans le monde c'est à peu près pareil
doua premier dilemme pour nos amis de la
sd développé au sens de la croissance du
pib un pays c'est nécessairement lui
permettre au sens où on l'entend
aujourd'hui d'avoir plus d'énergie
nécessaire je dis pas qu'il faut le
faire ou pas le faire jeudi c'est
nécessaire c'est indispensable
telle qu'on entend le pib aujourd'hui à
bas toute la question est de savoir si
augmenter le pib d'un pays est la bonne
manière de développer mais ça c'est un
autre débat
cette énergie c'est du carbone vous avez
ici l'approvisionnement énergétique
mondial depuis un siècle et demi et
c'est très simple on a dû carbone puis
du carbone puis du carbone c'est-à-dire
du charbon du pétrole et du gaz noté sur
ce graphique que la consommation de
charbon dans le monde n'a jamais baissé
depuis qu'on a commencé à utiliser du
charbon et non seulement elle n'a jamais
baissé mais sur les 15 dernières années
c'est ça l'idée très loin a augmenté le
plus vous montrerai juste après vous
verrez également que les énergies ne
sont en rien cannibaliser c'est à dire
que vous n'avez pas le pétrole qui a
remplacé le charbon le gaz qui a
remplacé le pétrole etc
pas du tout les énergies se sont
empilées les unes sur les autres et
enfin vous noterez que l'importance
réelle de l'énergie dans le monde est
inversement proportionnelle à sa
pagination leur journal français puisque
vous êtes assommé en ce moment deux
communiqués de presse sur le fait qu'il
ya du solaire l'éolien partout enfin
sauf que quand vous regardez ce pourquoi
ça compte vraiment dans le monde
c'est juste des cacahuètes quoi donc
c'est absolument pas ça qui va changer
quoi que ce soit à l'avenir énergétique
du monde dans les dix y est je ne leur
va pas changer grand chose
voilà l'arbre qui cache la forêt je me
suis amusé à regarder à fuser si on veut
à regarder quelle était la différence de
consommation énergétique dans le monde
énergie par nrj entre 2000 et 2014 bon
je le redis le communiqué de presse vous
explique que les investissements dans
les eaux de l'air dépassé les
investissements ne sais pas quoi qu on
en installe à tire larigot que machin
bref donc j'ai été regardé un truc tout
bête qu'il est de combien à augmenter la
production de chaque énergie entre 2000
2014 dans le monde vous voyez que le
premier gagnant enfin le lan arrive en
tête du podium
le charbon le charbon donc si la presse
reflétait ce qui se passe dans le monde
elle aurait pas dû vous parlez tous les
quatre matins solaire elle aurait dit
vous parlez tous les quatre matins de
chapon le deuxième sur le podium c'est
le gaz
le troisième c'est pétrole justement
liquide et même si on se limite aux jets
d'air la presse aurait dû vous paraît
tous les quatre matins les barrages
absolument pas des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires
d'accord donc à ce stade désolé pour les
journalistes il y en a dans la salle ne
croyez pas ce qui a dans le journal ça
n'est jamais opposable à quiconque
j'avais dit avant le journal n'engage
que le journal je le sais assez bien en
ce qui concerne les propres propos vous
voyez également que si vous faites une
petite règle de trois vous vous rendez
compte que l'un crémant sur le solaire
c'est à dire 42 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole et un 35e de l'unc
rhénan sur le char ou 1 35e
donc comme disait l'autre en parler ne
pas en parler
là n'est pas la question ce dont il faut
parler c'est tout ça parce que c'est ça
le problème
c'est ça le problème ceci alors avec
cela comme énergie égale co2 et bien
rebelote
dis moi combien tenait je te dirai à
quel niveau de pays les tuer voilà donc
en première approximation aujourd'hui je
lui en première approximation
aujourd'hui vous verrez qu'une règle de
3 à la fin sans vouloir me faire un
chantre de la décroissance je suis quand
même capable de vous dire une chose
faire baisser les émissions de co2 très
vite si vous allez voir qu'il faut les
faire baisser très vite avec un pib qui
croient pardon ça va pas être la même
lettre à la fin avec je n'y crois pas
une seconde je n'y crois pas une seconde
le découplage ça n'existe pas ça
n'existe pas donc la seule bonne
question pour nous maintenant c'est de
savoir si on considère que la provision
pour risques dont il faut grève et le
pib parce que omet du co2 par tous et
parce que soit dit en passant on est en
train de fiche en l'air la biodiversité
etc
elle est d'une ampleur telle que là où
on pense qu'on fait encore de la
croissance
on est déjà en train de faire de la
décroissance et on serait bien inspiré
d'en faire une autre plus soft c'est ça
la question aujourd'hui c'est pas est ce
qu'on peut avoir la croissance
perpétuelle avec le problème qui réglait
alors je sais pas exactement mais gagne
connaît peut-être la réponse barista
galbraith
on attribue cette petite formule qui est
si vous croisez quelqu'un qui vous
promet la croissance perpétuelle c'est
un fou ou un économiste bon
mais voilà donc vous voyez aujourd'hui
le gros dilemme et c'est pour ça que je
le sais parce que c'est lui qui me l'a
dit laly brice lalonde qui a fait à peu
près tout ce qui se fait sur terre
depuis 1972 en termes de somme et
environnementaux m'a dit un jour aux
négociations climat c'est très simple
les pays occidentaux viennent en pensant
qu'on va parler de climat les pays en
développement viennent en pensant qu'on
va parler de développement gestion
développement qui gagne à cause de 100
noëls pour diminuer nos émissions de co2
y penser même temps émettre du co2 dans
l'air engage irrémédiablement l'avenir
et quand je dis engage irrémédiablement
l'avenir il s'agit pas de la semaine
prochaine il s'agit de allez on va être
sympa de ce qui reste à vivre pour
l'humanité je pense si l'humanité va
dépasser de beaucoup de milan avec tout
ce qu'on est en train de faire en ce
moment donc ça engage vraiment ce qu'on
est en train de faire pour encore très
très longtemps
vous avez ici un graphique issu du
dernier rapport du giec qui vous donne
une indication qui est aujourd'hui je
mets un shoot de co2 dans l'atmosphère
le co2 et j'ai les miens dans
l'atmosphère donc je rajoute du co2 dans
l'atmosphère instantanément sa veut
créer un surplus de concentration de co2
dans l'atmosphère et le giec se pose la
question exactement les scientifiques
qui ont travaillé sur la question
cela pose c'est en avançant dans le
temps quelle est la fraction du co2 que
je viens de rajouter dans l'atmosphère
qui va y rester
au fil des années et alors les
scientifiques parce qu'ils sont que le
co2 est une molécule chimiquement
extrêmement inerte c'est le processus
est le résultat d'une oxydation
donc c'est un truc qui tient l'inerte
faut beaucoup d'énergie pour casser la
molécule de co2 du reste les planches le
sable faire qu'avec l'aide d'un photon
solaire ça peut le faire normalement et
se soucier aux deux donc c'est autant
comment keating paroles il reste dans
l'atmosphère où il sent très bien merci
vous n'avez que deux processus
d'épuration du co2 de l'atmosphère c'est
soit il se dissout dans l'océan ce n'est
pas un processus chimique c'est un
processus physiques soit il et photos
dissocier à la surface d'une feuille de
plantes ça c'est un processus photo
celik
il n'y a pas de processus strictement
civil d'épuration du co2 de la passe
r parce que le co2 est une molécule
extrêmement stable donc une fois que
vous l'avez mis dans l'air ici sont très
bien si vous enlevez pas pour le mettre
ailleurs
il y reste il va quand même finir par
être absorbé par la photosynthèse
si on en fait si on met juste une fois
du co2 dans l'eure et qu'on touche plus
à rien et il va aussi être absorbé par
les océans
mais tout ça est lent quand je serai
mort et vous aussi
il restera encore à peu près la moitié
du co2 émis aujourd'hui ou de la
concentration supplémentaire concret
aujourd'hui pour être plus précis il en
restera encore la moitié dans l'air
d'ici quelques dizaines d'années
si j'arrête des maîtres demain matin au
moment vos enfants même pour les plus
jeunes d'entre vous ce remords il
restera encore dans l'atmosphère une
petite moitié du surplus de
concentration en co2 que nous avons créé
aujourd'hui on passe à l'échelle des
temps historiques quelques siècles
il restera encore dans l'atmosphère un
tiers du surplus de concentration que
nous avons créé aujourd'hui ce que je
viens de vous dire c'est qu'il n'existe
pas de bouton reset pour le changement
climatique
on va faire l'expérience une seule fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
or nous avons un système basé sur ce que
nous comprenons de ce que nous disent
nos sens qui est un système globalement
essai/erreur anaf un enfant apprend que
ça brûle en mettant une fois le doigt là
où ça brûle et on espère qu'ils brûlent
pas trop fort et après il a compris il
apprend que sa pince en mettant une fois
ses doigts dans la porte
on n'espère pas trop fort et après il a
compris il apprend que rien glander à
l'école c'est pas terrible parce qu'il
se prend une fois un bulletin pas
terrible il se fait passer une danse et
après il a compris tous ceux d'entre
vous qui ont élevé des enfants ou qui
ont le souvenir de cette époque si vous
n'en avez pas encore élevés se
souviendront que la parole de l'adulte
c'est cause toujours autant qu'on n'a
pas fait sa propre expérience et qu'on a
compris là pas de pot on va pas pouvoir
faire l'expérience
dit autrement si on fait l'expérience
avec le résultat nous déplaît on a déjà
perdu on peut pas faire est ce l erreur
c'est exclu à cause de cette constante
de temps liée à la présence du co2 dans
l'air
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il
faut attendre du processus de
négociation en cours qu'ils règlent le
problème du premier coup donc là j'ai
déjà répondu ah j'ai coché une des cases
qu'attendent de la coop 21 qu'elle
contribue à ce que du premier coup en
règle le problème
vous verrez après si on peut considérer
que cette case là a été cochée ou pas
une fois qu'on a acquis le co2 dans
l'air comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure comme il s'en va pas dit ça fait
un surplus et ce surplus absorbent un
peu plus fort
le rayonnement infrarouge émis par la
terre puisque je vous rappelle par
définition à gaz à effet de serre est un
gaz qui présente des raies d'absorption
dans les infrarouges émis par la terre
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont des vieux
souvenirs de mécanique quantique
ça veut tout simplement dire que le saut
d'énergie des électrons correspond à
l'énergie transportée par le rayonnement
infrarouge émis par la surface terrestre
c'est tout bêtement ça que ça veut dire
donc c'est des trucs je le redis il n'y
a rien là dedans qui pourrait donner
raison à monsieur allègre
du reste les climato-sceptiques et
nuisible pour la santé il approuvait
donc cette fabia rien de y'a rien
d'extraordinaire c'est juste le goût
pour la polémique des médias qui lui a
fait qui a fait qu'il posait dans le
micro c'est des choses qui sont très
bien connus et du reste forte utilisée
par les astrophysiciens par exemple donc
une fois que je mets co2 dans l'air il
absorbe des infrarouges terrestre et ce
faisant ça confine un peu plus l'énergie
radiative de la terre près du sol et
donc ça va déformer le profil vertical
de température de l'atmosphère plus
chaud en va plus froid en eau
je rappelle qu'une des conséquences du
changement climatique c'est que certes
ça se réchauffe près du sol les ca sont
refroidis dans la haute atmosphère
augmentant ainsi le gradient de
température de la troposphère ce qui va
augmenter le moteur de tous les
phénomènes convectifs et donc des des
phénomènes extrêmes
donc il ya une raison physique de base à
ce que l'intensité des phénomènes
extrêmes augmente dans un climat qui se
réchauffe par supplément d'effet de
serre c'est normal il n'y a rien
d'extraordinaire à 100 vous avez ici un
diagramme qui a été produit par le giec
aussi et qui met en perspective
l'élévation de température déjà
constatée sur le xxème siècle et puis ce
que ça pourrait être à l'avenir
fonction de combien on va rajouter de
co2 dans l'atmosphère de co2 est en fait
d'autres gaz à effet de serre alors
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure à
cause de la durée de vie du co2 dans
l'atmosphère pour que la température
n'augmente plus trop à la nouvelle va
augmenter quand même il faut que dès
demain matin
les émissions mondiales qui augmente
d'environ 2% par an ce fait a baissé de
3% par an 4 demain matin demain matin
aux obstacles toute augmentation de la
population envie d'avoir des bagnoles
c'est pourquoi crack moins de -3% en
vous avez un autre scénario possible qui
est que les émissions restent au niveau
auquel elles sont et c est ce que vous
voyez c'est que en fonction de là où
iront ou là où irez plus exactement les
émissions parce que vous verrez à la fin
de cette présentation un excellent
bouquin que je viens d'écrire dans
lequel j'explique pourquoi je ne prends
pas une seconde que l'on va aller vers
10 milliards de terriens qui vont
émettre comme un polonais les
rétroactions du système sur l'humanité
se chargeront de nous calmer
bien avant qu'on arrive à ce niveau là
gala dit autrement il commencera à y
avoir la guerre partout bien avant qu'on
arrive à ce niveau là qu'est ce que
c'est que quelques des deux changements
de température moyenne alors là aussi
désolé pour ceux qui ont déjà vu cette
planche 50 fois mais pour les autres je
pense que ça peut être utile
vous avez ici un une représentation
schématique de ce qu'on appelle les
écosystèmes climax hic c'est à dire ceux
qui s'installent si l'homme n'est pas là
pour lors d enlever pour y installer à
la place des chants des églises des
routes ou des centrales électriques
donc c'est les écosystèmes qui sont
naturellement présentes dans une zone si
on leur fiche la paix vous voyez qu'en
europe
aujourd'hui les écosystèmes qui sont
naturellement présents sont
essentiellement des forêts donc c'est
des grosses plantes pour la partie
aérienne
ça veut dire que il fait 10 trop froid
ni trop chaud et qui peut commencer
cette série
voilà l'europe d'il y a vingt mille ans
alors l'europe il ya vingt mille ans est
sensiblement différente de l'europe que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
le trait de côte que vous voyez en noir
n est pas du tout au même endroit et
l'europe via mains vides en prière
évident parce qu'on va nous sommes à ce
moment là au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire vous savez que l'on voit
l'ère quaternaire on oscille entre
glaciaires et interglaciaires une
sincérité 3 interglaciaire il fait chaud
et ça s'appelle inter glaciaire et non
pas chaud parce que à l'échelle des
temps géologiques c'est beaucoup plus
court que les à place hier en gros
pendant le quaternaire vous avez 100 me
dans des glacières un bilan d'air inter
glaciaire qui pas fort passant milan de
la cire d'un bilan des interfaces hier
et on doit cette petite fantaisie de
notre système climatique au fait que
nous ne sommes pas seuls à tourner
autour du soleil et que l'orbité
terrestre été formés par l'attraction
des grosses planètes du système solaire
notamment jupiter et saturne et que du
coup sa cause alors big thérèse des
petites perturbations qui vont elles
mènent engendré des grands effets comme
disait à bar sur le climat qu'il fait
sur terre et donc sans milan glacière à
milan l'inter glacière et crack
on ya deux parties donc il ya vingt
mille ans on est au coeur de la dernière
ère glaciaire
alors là aussi le dictionnaire est bien
fait si on est en guerre de l'acier
ailleurs séquelles la glace
et effectivement je suis désolé pour les
étudiants dans cette salle
erasmus avec la suède c'est pas possible
et on peut parler formé comme 44 l'a
fait récemment des fonctionnaires du
maghreb en suède je peux demander pour
comprendre et à les former des
fonctionnaires du matériau en suède mais
enfin on nous a quand même payer pour ça
donc vous avez une calotte glaciaire de
quelques kilomètres d'épaisseur
d'énormes glaciers posé sur la
scandinavie et du reste il ya sa grande
soeur sur le canada qui fait à peu près
la même épaisseur le groenland a grossi
et l'antarctique aussi et ceci allant
avec cela comme quand les calottes se
forme il faut bien prendre l'eau quelque
part l'eau a été prise dans les océans
le fond de l'océan n'ayant pas bougé le
niveau de l'eau s'il en a b c et donc
l'océan et plus bas de 120 mètres donc
on peut aller fiche la pâtée aux
irlandaises ont enfin réussi à faire
séparés depuis quatre ans à pied sec pas
la peine de prendre mon tunnel
pas la peine de se ruiner en prenant
eurostar c'est pas la peine les
irlandais sont accessibles à pied les
écossais ne sont plus une nuisance pour
le tournoi des six nations 6 sous la
glace et ceux d'entre vous qui aime bien
les
joseph ged merise moment où il ya plus
d'une chose s est tenue des collines
dont klaus ayant abaissé de 100 et vous
pouvez rentrer dans la grotte cosquer
pied pour ceux d'entre vous qui
connaissent donc c'est une grotte qui
est sur la méditerranée
aujourd'hui oui il fait froid
donc il fait sec dans un climat froid
l'évaporation est beaucoup plus faible
la pression de vapeur saturante en eau
est beaucoup plus basse et donc le cycle
de l'eau et beaucoup moins intense
donc non seulement il fait froid mais il
fait sec du coup la végétation en france
ressemble peu ou est-ce que vous avez au
nord de la sibérie actuelle la capacité
de charge de la france à cette époque là
est à peu près la population de boulogne
billancourt je n'ai rien contre les
boulonnais billancourt roi pour revendre
donc j'ai rien pour les habitants à
boulogne billancourt et c'est juste pour
dire voilà la population française ces
boîtes vie en cours à l'époque un peu
moins même c'est de l'ordre de 100 vie
de bon vin et bien la différence de
température moyenne entre ces deux
paysages ces cinq domaines
dit autrement quand on est passé du
paysage de gauche au paysage de droite
tout ce que la terre a fait c'est se
réchauffer de 5 degrés en quelques
milliers d'années
donc vous avez là l'effet de long terme
d'une élévation de température qui a été
limitée à 0,1 degré par siècle sur 57
j'en tire deux conclusions
la première c'est que si la température
devait à partir de maintenant non pas se
réchauffer mais se refroidir de 5 degrés
je peux déjà vous dire que ça fait trois
bières demain parce que ça rend toutes
les moyennes latitudes incultivables
donc je pense que je suis à peu près
dans les eaux 5 degrés en plus je le
redis personne n'a jamais fait
l'expérience
jamais la dernière fois qu'on a eu 5
degrés en plus on a eu 50 siècles pour
s'adapter et à l'époque les unités
humaine qui devaient s'y adapter et qui
s'y sont adaptés en tant qu'espèce
puisqu'on déjà parfaitement bien passé à
travers le problème en tant qu'espèce je
leur disais exactement comme l'espèce
humaine a très bien survécu aux pestes
du moyen âge à représentants du sur deux
de l'espèce a pas trouvé ça drôle mais
l'espèce a extrêmement bien survécu
un objet d aucune angoisse sur le fait
qu'on va survivre aux changements
climatiques en tant qu'espèce aucun
doute là dessus nombre de représentants
de l'espèce et l'espérance de vie des
représentants de l'espèce
enfin je pense que c'est une question
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir j'ai
désolé c'est du franglais parce que je
suis fainéant j'ai pas eu le temps de se
dire qu'est ce qu'on peut avoir comme
conséquence il va y avoir une pression
sur les rendements agricoles
il va y avoir une pression sur les
écosystèmes non dirigé il va y avoir une
modification de la biodiversité des
agents pathogènes parce que la
biodiversité des agents pathogènes c'est
aussi quelque chose qui existe est en
général quand le bouillon de culture
chauffe les petites bêtes aime bien ça
il va y avoir une augmentation des
vagues de chaleur
il va y avoir une dilatation de l'eau
sous l'effet de la chaleur donc une
montée du niveau de l'eau plus une fonte
des calottes glaciaires et une fonte des
glaciers continentaux donc à nouveau une
hausse du niveau de l'eau une partie du
co2 étant repris par l'océan
certains d'entre vous qui ont lu jules
verne se rappelle peut-être que le co2
s'appelle acide carbonique dans les
romans de jules verne parce que quand
vous mettez du co2 dans l'eau sale
acidifie or le côté alcalin de l'eau est
indispensable à ce qu'une bonne partie
des organismes marins synthétise du
calcaire qui est indispensable à faire
des coquilles ou des squelettes et dès à
présent vous commencez à avoir en
arctique des zones dont la le ph est
devenu trop petit pour que une petite
fraction pour le moment des organismes
arrive à ça à synthétiser l'eau calcaire
qui va bien puisque plusieurs formes de
calcaire pour que ces organismes
puissent survivre
donc là on a une pression sur la vie
marine et là dedans il ya du plant on va
avoir une modification de la circulation
à grande échelle de l'océan
on va avoir comme je disais tout à
l'heure une intensification des
phénomènes extrêmes
globalement le groenland a commencé à
fondre
il va continuer à le faire jusqu'à la
prochaine entrée en négociation si tant
est qu'elle arrive parce que ça va
dépendre de l'ampleur du changement
climatique que nous sommes en train
déclenchée pour l'avant toutes les
simulations basées sur les paramètres
astronomiques de la terre montre que
même si on fait les zazous finira par y
avoir de nouveau une en triant
glaciation enfin dans trente ou quarante
mille ans donc c'est pas vraiment
quelque chose qui va permettre de
compenser ce qui se passe en ce moment
et il est même possible qu'on met
tellement le système en équilibre
cueillant dépend en fait encore une fois
sont plus vraiment là pour voir le
résultat
par contre ce qui est sûr c'est que le
groenland a commencé à fondre et il va
continuer à le faire parce que plus ils
font plus les mécanismes d'amplification
dur
son local sont pas pourtant il va
continuer à le faire et ça ça va nous
amener n'importe quoi entre un et six
mètres dos en plus dans les océans dans
le siècle à venir
vous avez un certain nombre de stocks de
carbone qui était immobilisé depuis des
millions d'années où des dizaines de
millions d'années qui sont susceptibles
d'être mis en circulation
en particulier dans les hydrates de
méthane et ça c'est la bouteille
rentrent en gros c'est un énorme point
d'interrogation sais pas si c'est un
truc marginal 6 est susceptible d'être
très désagréable et tout ça va avoir des
effets directs et surtout indirects et
surtout à direct sur la stabilité des
sociétés humaines et l'espérance de vie
et les liens seront toujours un
directeur n'est pas tant ce soir mais
dans toujours l'excellent livre que je
vous conseille
il ya tout un chacun dans lequel ge
explique en quoi les printemps arabes on
détermine en énergie climat absolument
majeur c'est que s'ils sont déclenchés
en 2011 et pas un autre moment il faut y
voir la trace du changement climatique
et de la question énergétique dans le
monde
les deux ont joué un rôle absolument
central et c'est aussi vrai pour la
syrie donc les conséquences du
changement climatique si je suis un peu
caricatural vous n'avez pas besoin
d'aller les chercher en 2100 et sont aux
portes de l'ordre aujourd'hui elles sont
aux portes de l'europe
aujourd'hui n'allez pas les chercher
ailleurs on en a déjà la trace le propre
d'une expérience qu'on fait pour la
première fois c'est qu'on peut pas tout
prévoir
alors je vais prendre me pardonnerez
seul un petit parallèle un certain
nombre d'entre vous dans cette salle
sont mariés florent j'imagine le mariage
est une expérience que l'humanité a dû
faire jeu pour 1 3 milliard de fois 2
milliards 4 milliards enfin bon un
certain nombre de fois et bien pour
autant vous prenez un couple qui se
marie aujourd'hui vous êtes un foutu de
savoir où j'en suis content donc prenez
une expérience sur laquelle on a un bon
dessert absolument considérables déjà
pas foutu de savoir tellement le système
est incertain où ça nous emmènera il ya
des trucs que vous pouvez dire c'est
absolument de certains que dans trente
ans ils ont pu un temps absolument
certain vous n'êtes absolument certain
que s'ils n'ont pas eu d'enfant dans les
30 ou 40 ans qui viennent
sauf madame italienne qui s'est fait
fécondés in vitro la vraie semblablement
viendront pas il ya des trucs que vous
pouvez dire en négatif truc que vous
voyez en positif compliqué et un savoir
où ils habiteront ce qu'ils font et
c'est toujours vivant
donc là vous prenez une expérience que
nous n'avons jamais fait sur une
humanité peuplée de sept milliards
d'individus avec des asservissements et
des rétroactions dans absolument tous
les sens ça n'a strictement aucun sens
de demander à la communauté scientifique
de vous quantifier ex ante et les
risques que nous courons
ce qui soit dit en passant me fait dire
que stern l'orb a joué un rôle
extrêmement utile quand il a dit on
risque de perdre 6 % du pib
il aurait aussi bien pu dire 98 tous
deux c'était pareil il n'y a aucun
calcul rationnel qui puisse mettre
derrière ce truc là aucun et à mon avis
du reste à 5 degrés on est beaucoup plus
près de 98 2 6 donc le donc n'essayez
pas de faire un calcul rationnel
derrière ce truc là c'est c'est très
utile pour que les gens se remue ça n'a
aucune valeur académique n'a aucune
valeur académique parce que vous n'êtes
pas capable de prédire l'évolution des
sous jacents physique du pib et aucune
capacité prédictive là dessus donc ça
sera compris entre 0 et 100 voilà
maintenant une deuxième droite qu'il est
essentiel d'avoir en tête
si on veut savoir apprécier les
résultats de la coop 21 donc vous avez
vu tout à l'heure le première droite
essentiel pib quelle énergie pib égal
co2 industrie & gas l'énergie au ventre
à droite et vous avez une correspondance
mondiale parfaite au niveau d'un pays
quand vous avez des effets de bord ça
match pas toujours dans le même sens au
niveau mondial ça marcherait deuxième
droite absolument essentiel à avoir en
tête c'est celle ci cette droite
elle met en perspective les émissions
cumulées de l'humanité depuis 1850 que
vous avez ici sur l'axé horizontal et le
réchauffement planétaire que nous aurons
entre 1850 et 2100 alors applications
pratiques à fin 2015
l'humanité avait émis environ 2000
milliards de tonnes de co2 dont la
décomposition vous apparaît ici
donc vous voyez en première le charbon
en deuxième gros sujets pour l'afd la
déforestation et au lieu de
mettre l'argent du contribuable français
dans des panneaux solaires je pense
qu'on ferait mieux de le mettre dans la
lutte contre la déforestation
je pense qu'on vendrait un bien meilleur
service au climat si on faisait ce genre
de choses pas comme ça qu'on entend des
verts et vous voyez derrière qu'arrive
le pardon le pétrole puis le gars donc
j'ai demi milliard de tonnes je reporte
l'intersection de ma droite verticale
avec cette série de courbes de l'armée
qui décide en gros une droite et ça me
donne
l'élévation de température pour laquelle
on a déjà signé en 2100 alors vous voyez
aujourd'hui plus ou moins une barre
d'erreurs on a signé pour 1,2 mais si on
est du côté pas de chance on a déjà
signé pour 1,5 donc faut-il attendre de
la coop qu'on passe encore du temps à
discuter de la manière de ramener le
réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degré
dont celle perdre de temps complète
aucun intérêt aucun intérêt ça
n'arrivera pas aucun intérêt vous allez
voir que si on veut limiter à 2° déjà on
est qui font penser l'économie comme
d'économie de guerre c'est à dire que si
on se met pas en écho david kerr vous
pouvez aussi oublier les 2 degrés
pourquoi parce que si vous faites le
processus de manière inversée ray une
droite ces objections vous rappelez
d'accord donc pour une valeur sûre lax
désordonnée vous n'avez qu'une seule
valeur sur l'axé des abscisses ça fait
partie des charmes de ce genre de courbe
donc si vous voulez limiter à 2 degrés
et bien cette petite série de coups
membres vous dit que vous avez droit à
trois mille milliards de tonnes de co2
entre 1850 et 2100 dont 2000 ont déjà
été émises donc malgré l'heure avancée
de la journée je passe quand on est à
boire après vous êtes capable de faire
la différence 3000 - de villalbe il
moi j'y arrive donc il nous reste 1000
milliards de tonnes à émettre d'ores et
déjà
comprenez que on a émis 2000 alors que
l'humanité est passé de 0 5 à 7
milliards de bons hommes
il faudra y mettre que bill alors qu'on
devrait rester de 7 à 9
jeudi 11 degrés c'est un scénario dans
ce qu'il va se passer
c'est pas du tout cuit et pas du tout
cuit accord et les deux degrés c'est ça
qu'ils disent le degré c'est ça qui dit
il et on a encore mille milliards de
tonnes pour 7 à 9 milliards de pékin
avec quoi est ce que je peux faire mille
milliards de tonnes de co2 et bien par
exemple je peux les faire en brûlant en
totalité le charbon contenues dans les
réserves prouvées de la région
asie-pacifique + un petit morceau de
l'union de l'ex union soviétique et puis
c'est tout je pense plus au pétrole et
je touche plus au gaz à partir de demain
matin et je trouve plus au charbon ni en
europe ni dans en amérique du nord
je veux faire tout et donc demain matin
vous avez plus de bagnoles
il ya plus de camions et vous n'avez
plus de chauffage au gaz mais à cette
condition je peux toucher au charbon qui
reste dans le sous sol de la zone asie
pacifique dont vous pourrez toujours
acheter des smartphone made in taiwan
dont vous ne pourrez pas vous servir
on pourra plus produire d'électricité on
en manque donc vous avez une petite idée
de ce dans quoi on est alors je peux
aussi parce que si on fait la somme des
barres rouges là ça c'est pour la vie
olivier on peut encore se servir de tout
le pétrole dont on dispose sur terre
mais demain matin je touche plus au
charbon je touche biogaz à nouveau tous
ceux d'entre vous qui sont chauffés au
gaz vous oublié et il n'y a plus un
gramme d'électricité enfin un
kilowattheure d'électricité qui sort
d'une centrale à charbon à partir de
demain matin
or je vous rappelle que dans le monde le
charbon est de très loin la première
source de production électrique ceci va
avec cela c'est pour ça qu'il attend aux
comptes et 40 % d'électricité mondiale
est faite au charbon est symétriquement
les deux tiers du charbon servent à
produire d'électricité
vous avez à ce moment en ce moment au
moment où je vous parle là dans le monde
1800 gigawatts de centrales à charbon
dans le monde
pour mémoire les nucléaire qui nous
excite pas en france et 60 ans à 63,60
gigawatts de nucléaire en france
1806 à houat de charbon dans le monde
pour respecter les deux degrés ce que je
vais vous dire dans pas longtemps c'est
qu'il faut tout les met à la ferraille
dans les trente cinq ans qui viennent
absolument tout parce que si l'afd a un
mandat et un seul en fait il a deux
branches déforestation centrales à
charbon le reste qu'on peut oublier
déforestation sont pas le charbon le
restant dû une fois je vais reprendre
des termes un peu barbare quand je dis
qu'on a encore droit d'émettre mille
milliards de tonnes de co2 d'ici à 2100
ça veut dire que l'intégrale de ma
courbe des missions futures est limité à
1000 milliards de tonnes de co2 d'accord
donc j'ai une fonction qui sont les
émissions futures dont le cumul c'est
sale intégral dont le cumul est limitée
et bien à ce moment ma fonction si elle
n'a pas une tête trop bizarroïdes je
suis capable de la tracé et c'est très
exactement ce que dit ce graphique
à partir du moment où la surface sous la
courbe ici là vous êtes à 0,1
elle est limitée à 1000 milliards de
tonnes équivalent demi milliard de
tonnes équivalent co2 eh bien ça veut
dire que je n'ai droit qu'à la courbe du
bas toutes les autres sont trop hélas
compte du bas me dit que d'ici à 2050 je
dois avoir divisé par trois les
émissions planétaires d'ici à 2050
après tout les gens que j'entends tout
le temps dans les jolis quartiers de
paris dira mais il faut que les
africains et de l'énergie j'ai une très
bonne nouvelle pour eux à ce moment je
suis d'accord les africains ont de
l'énergie du coup vous en avez encore
moins aucun problème parce que c'est le
gâteau global qui est vu par atmosphère
l'atmosphère se contrefout des émissions
par personne tout ce qu'elle voit elle
sait les émissions globales
donc si on veut que les émissions
globales des autres ventes va nous
animer - alors en général les gens à qui
je dis ça tout d'un coup ils se disent
que c'est pas sûr que voilà et en fait
vous vous rendez compte que tous ces
gens là et ça aussi c'est très bien dans
ce pays utilise les africains comme
cache sexe contre fout des africains
tout ce qui compte c'est qu'ils
préservent leur niveau de vie à eux
sinon il ya très longtemps que 20% du
pib français iraient dans l'aide au
développement et sauf erreur de ma part
je crois pas que ce soit le cas
donc j'ai vu surgir deux pics
m'intéresse aux changements climatiques
les africains l'aide à l'afrique comme
par magie
depuis que les gens ont la trouille pour
leur propre niveau de vie voilà c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer les en
général c'est le cache sexe parce que
les ventes juste pas envie de dessins de
leur médium donc si on est sérieux sur
cette affaire on divise par trois je le
rappelle les constantes de temps font
qu'on va gérer deux problèmes en même
temps donc on va devoir gérer
la baisse des émissions de co2 en fait
on va aller on va gérer leur baisse même
si on veut pas parce que comme les
combustibles fossiles sont en quantité
donnée une fois pour toutes il ya un
autre petit théorème de batz qui dit que
vous pouvez pas avoir une consommation
carburant croissante de combustibles
fossiles
ça marche pas avec le fait que le
sous-sol en contient une quantité de
données une fois pour toutes
en fait les maths disent que vous êtes
obligés d'être passé par un maximum
était 100 derrière donc les émissions de
co2 même si on veut pas viendra un jour
où elles passeront par un maximum et
elle ne croîtront derrière à cause de
l'inertie chimique s'est pas à ce moment
là que le co2 baissent dans l'atmosphère
à cause de l'inertie thermique ce n'est
pas à ce moment là que la température
atmosphérique se met à baisser et à
cause de l'inertie des océans c'est pas
à ce moment là que l'océan arrête de se
dilater
donc je le répète les conséquences de ce
que nous attendre à de faire aujourd'hui
vont se mettre à croître pendant des
décennies des siècles et des millénaires
après qu'on ait passé le maximum d
émission
donc plus on attend et plus on se
retrouve dans un problème qui est je
gère une quantité croissante
d'emmerdements avec une quantité
décroissante de moyens pour y faire face
c'est ça l'inaction c'est ça si on veut
agir
alors je vous propose une règle de trois
qui est bien connu des spécialistes du
secteur qui s'appelle l'équation de
kayar monsieur caillé existent vraiment
ce n'est pas un accroc ni de yaka et
l'équation de kayes a dit la chose
suivante elle commence par dire que les
émissions planétaires de gaz à effet de
serre sont égale à elle même ce sur quoi
je crois devrait être d'accord
après quoi je vais divisé multiplier le
terme de droite par la quantité
d'énergie utilisée dans le monde et donc
là je fais apparaître un premier terme
co2 sur tech qui et combien je vais de
co2 dans l'atmosphère quand j'utilise
une unité d'énergie quand j'utilise à
kilowattheures d'énergie charbon pétrole
gaz kilowattheure ces trois millions 600
mille joue bien donc c'est n'importe
quelle énergie que je peux compter en
kilowattheures c'est pas juste de
l'électricité on l'utilisera
kilowattheures d'énergie convient ce que
je vais être c'est au dollar ensuite je
vais divisé x le pile alors pourquoi je
fais pas ça avec les oursins les étoiles
de mer où le nombre de chaussettes dans
la garde-robe de gaël parce que je
pourrai le faire ça resterait
mathématiquement exact que j'en tirerai
aucune conclusion
alors que là quand je mets
énergie en eau et euros en bas dollars
en bas j'ai comme je le disais tout à
l'heure compter avec deux unités de
compte différentes
le même processus physiques qui
s'appelle de la transformation qui
permet de passer du minatd faire à la
fourchette et de la fourchette à la
brasserie qui est en face de la gare de
lyon parce que même les services ont
besoin de cette transformation
et enfin je termine en divisant et en
multipliant par la population et donc je
fais apparaître cette équation infernal
très désagréable monstrueusement casse
tête qui est que les émissions
augmentent à mesure de la population
donc on a un sujet démographique 2 du
pib par personne
donc on a un sujet économique 2
la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise pour
provoquer une transformation ça
s'appelle l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie et enfin d énergie que nous
choisissons ou de la nature choisi pour
nous et c'est notre contenu en gaz
carbonique de ménage et je dis ça je
dois divisé par trois d'ici 2050 mais ça
mon cahier des charges des parts d'accor
et je rajoute et le sera parce que même
si on veut pas à cause de la contrainte
géologique ultime sur les combustibles
fossiles qui vaut mieux ne pas attendre
pour climat mais qui est déjà à l'oeuvre
pour l'europe et étrangers sur le gaz et
sur le charbon sous les 3 et bien il ya
des zones en quantité croissante ou de
toute façon qu'on leur demandera pas
leur avis c'est ce qui va se passer avec
à la clé des déconfiture économique en
cascade et qui quand c'est des
démocraties face aux problèmes aux
promesses inconsidérées amèneront la
venue au pouvoir de populiste aussi sûr
que deux et deux font quatre
quand on regarde la population rares
sont les gens qui proposent à l'aiguillé
partira quelques personnes bientôt une
audience faible en général les scénarios
prévoient alors moi j'adore les
scénarios qui prévoient en matière
démographique vous prévoyez rien du tout
s'il ya une baisse théorique qui tombe
sur une comète tombe sur la terre dans
vingt ans comme les dinosaures ont
expérimenté il ya 65 millions d'années
passées à tous un bon projet vous ne
savez pas une je ne sais pas si la
prochaine grande épidémie ticp est dans
le monde ça sera dans dix ans dans 20
ans dans deux siècles de trois videurs
oubliez-vous non plus donc pour le
moment on travaille avec des scénarios
le scénario vous dis c'est là dessus
qu'on va continuer pour la suite parce
que sinon on peut pas continuer vos 10 +
21% alors là la règle de trois est
impitoyable si la gauche doit diviser
par 3 et à droite je commence par x 1,25
ça veut dire qu en première
approximation je dois diviser le reste
par quatre jeux 3,75
je le fais à 4 deuxième solution serait
divisé le pib par personne par quatre là
aussi rares sont les candidats aux voix
qui propose ça vous mariez pas trop je
pense que ça va être une des manières
dont le problème va se régler a
volontairement serre a déjà commencé en
europe
mais quand vous allez demander au comité
d'orientation des retraites qui vous
disent non et je vois 2 % par an on
scénario raisonnable c'est 2 % par an
jusqu'en 2050 et là vous n'aurez pas non
plus il a vraiment sage dans le document
du comité d'orientation des retraites
donc je pense qu'on devrait supprimer la
solde de ces fonctionnaires pas possible
de raconter des conneries pareilles
donc on dit + 2 % par an jusqu'en 2050
aucun problème alors excellent fera pour
vous 1,02 à l'appui 135
sinon on fait plus cher l'exercice et
vous verrez que ça fait à peu près fois
deux en vingt ans en 36 ans parmi 35 et
si on est à 4 % par an alors je laisse
encore parce que la première fois j'ai
montré ce truc là il ya dix ans il ya
des gens qui y croyaient encore
maintenant quand même les gens se disent
si on veut 2% par an c'est bien ça vous
ferait folk mais partons sur x 2 donc x
1,25 la population x 2 le pib par
personne via fois deux et demi donc ça
veut dire que nous autres bras tragédie
heures en charge du mix énergétique est
en charge de l'efficacité énergétique
on est prié parce que le consommateur a
aucune envie de descons sommet et que
leur producteur a aucune envie de des
reproducteurs et bien on est prié de
trouver une solution qui divise par 7.5
les deux termes qui reste si on fait pas
madame royal nous explique qu'on est les
abrutis et consorts dans le monde nous
explique que c'est vraiment pas bien bon
regardons ce qu'ont fait les ingénieurs
dans le passé voici une courbe qui vous
donne d'évolution de l'efficacité
énergétique de l'économie sur les seins
en dernière année c'est un index eh bien
vous voyez que c'était constant jusqu'au
choc pétrolier puis crs et puis sur les
15 dernières années s'est de nouveau
constant donc l'économie n'a pas
progressé d'un iota sur les 15 dernières
années malgré l'explosion des
technologies de l'information donc
pardon jean-manuel on nous rebat les
oreilles toute la journée en nous
expliquant que c'est ça qui
dématérialise l'économie bullshit
goodship l'économie est aussi
matérielles aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était il ya 15 ans aussi matérielles
aujourd'hui quelqu'un vous ne regardez
jamais une partie d'un système quand
vous voulez apprécier la performance de
l'ensemble ça c'est une connerie de base
pourtant c'est fait absolument partout
bon alors on se dit ah ben imaginons que
les ingénieurs il soit pas meilleur plus
tard qu'ils ne l'ont été
ils ont gagné 30 % en trente ans ils
vont regagner 30 % en 30 ans mais 30 %
ça fait pas toujours ça fait toujours
pas une division par sept et donc ça
veut dire que sur le dernier terme c'est
de gagner un facteur 6 dans les trente
cinq ans qui viennent
alors que j'ai gagné 10 % 10 % sur les
50 dernières années et que depuis
l'explosion des renouvelables qui a
commencé en 2000 ça a cessé de
s'améliorer
tout simplement parce qu'on ne prend pas
de charbon bis repetita voilà donc si on
est vraiment sérieuse sur les 2 degrés
je ne vois pas une seule seconde comment
on peut éviter le débat sur ces deux
termes là pas une seconde
pas une seconde est-ce que la coop 21 à
parler de ces deux termes là évidemment
pas évidemment pas est-ce que les
leviers pour parler de ces deux termes
là sont à la coop 21 évidemment temps
c'est pas les nations unies qui ont la
charge de décider si la france doit ou
pas maintenir les allocations familiales
qui sont progressifs en fonction du
groupe d'enfants pas son job
n'attendez pas qu'elle le fasse elle ne
le fera pas ça n'est pas non plus les
nations unies qui vont décider de savoir
si on provoque délibérément une
contraction du pib ou pas les outils
pour décider ou pour gérer quand ont
suivi ce genre de trucs sous par la main
des nations unies
petite illustration de ce que je viens
de vous dire le très respectable giec
s'est amusé à regarder dans les quatre
termes de l'équation de callas qui avait
contribué à la hausse des émissions par
dc 10 et vous voyez que c'est des grands
taquin il explique quand on s'enrichit
et qu on est plus nombreux et bien ça va
pas vraiment un bon sens ils sont
vraiment très taquin ces gens là alors
maintenant on va regarder ce qu'il faut
faire si on veut vraiment faire baisser
les émissions alors voici un camembert
anonymisées où vous allez voir
apparaître comme par magie grâce à
l'informatique les différentes
composantes des émissions planétaires
legros camembert à grosse part de
camembert à 21%
c'est bravo et centrales à charbon les
centrales à charbon représente 20 %
un cinquième des émissions planétaires
après nous allons avoir les centrales
électriques au gaz et au fioul
il existe toujours des centrales à fuel
presqu'autant en 1973 en proportion
beaucoup moins en quantité on valeur
absolue presqu'autant est et centrale à
gaz 7 % des émissions 5 % des émissions
mondiales sont le fait de la fabrication
du ciment
sachant que le reste de l'industrie fait
10% et dans le reste de l'industrie vous
avez encore la fabrication de l'acier
qui fait quelque chose de pas très
éloignées entre 3 et 5%
parce que c'est difficile de dérivés des
statistiques mondiales sur la production
d'acier ce qui vient très exactement du
recyclage est ce qui vient de la
production primaire mais en gros vous
avez vous sachant que construire
aujourd'hui hélas à nouveau un sujet
pour la sd mais aussi pour la pour la
france c'est le ciment sert à construire
25 % de l'acier en europe sert à
construire j'ai pas quelle est la part
dans les pays émergents avant lui ses
supérieurs vous voyez que le fait de
construire
vous êtes quelque part entre 5 et 10%
des émissions planétaires
est-ce qu'on peut toujours construire
autant de tube en béton
si on veut être sérieux sur les 2 2 je
ne suis pas complètement persuadé le
chauffard est des bâtiments en émission
directe c'est-à-dire de chaudières qui a
vraiment dans les bâtiments ses 6 % des
émissions planétaires mais ça ça ne
tient pas compte de la climatisation ou
les émissions sont ici et là les
émissions directes de la production
d'électricité sont là et donc il
faudrait remettre dans confort thermique
la part qui va dans la clé
mais dans certains états show est avancé
entre l'hiver hong kong par exemple
singapour et bien la climatisation
représente plus de la moitié de
l'électricité qui est consommé si vous
n'avez pas beaucoup d'industries par le
parlement après vous avez quatre ans
qu'on sent qu'il ya les transports alors
dans les transports vous avez quatre
morceaux vers les voitures
retenez que en ordre de grandeur les
voitures dans le monde c'est pas plus
d'émissions que les cimenteries dans le
monde
comme on n'est pas en train de parler
juste du poème des bagnoles quand on
parle des émissions les camions c'est un
peu moins que les voitures mais c'est
significativement moins dans les pays
low cdo parfois significativement plus
dans les pays hors ocde et la marine
marchande et l'aviation font entre 2 et
3 l'acd paraissait difficile de trouver
des statistiques extrêmement fiable mais
en gros voilà à peu près ce que ça
représente l'agriculture représentant
d'émissions directes 20 % et en
émissions à bon sujet impute l'essentiel
de la déforestation au fait de défricher
des surfaces pour l'agriculture un petit
10 % retenez que manger c'est 30 % de
nos émissions des gaz à effet de serre
et en occident il ya un élément qui a
une responsabilité première la danse et
la conservation viande de boeuf
plus exactement l'existence d'un cheptel
bob ski c'est pas le sujet du jour mais
je pense que il y aurait bien d'autres
choses à faire avec les éleveurs
français que de libéraliser la
production et de les inciter à faire des
fermes de millevaches
je pense que l'europe faut que la
commission est en train de se fourrer le
doigt dans l'oeil jusqu'au plexus a reçu
dans ce genre besoin après vous avez des
tables bricole la gestion des déchets
les gaz fluorés pour ce qu'il en reste
et c'est je prends les émissions
actuelles il est divisé par trois j'ai
deux options
je peux dire je prends chaque morceau du
camembert et je divise par trois je fais
trois fois moins une centrale à charbon
trois fois moins de voitures trois fois
moins deux cimenteries trois fois moins
d'acier trois bogueys de suite pro forma
dassier c'est compliqué d'avoir le
pouvoir d'achat préservé et de continuer
à pouvoir acheter des sets de table chez
ikea au même prix va pas vraiment arrivé
1 3 fois moins de textile 3 ferment et
cetera trois formats de tous donc ça
revient à dire que votre pouvoir d'achat
je divise par trois en première partie
alors une bonne nouvelle pour vous ça en
prend le chemin mais c'est pas vraiment
la promesse électorale en règle générale
et puis j'ai une deuxième option qui est
le plus discriminé donc je dis là dedans
il ya des parts de camembert que j'ai
quand même envie de garder plus que
d'autres alors il y aura un vide que
j'ai envie de faire sont et avant toutes
les autres centrales à charbon et de là
deux options ou bien les gens acceptent
le nucléaire qui est de très loin la
solution la plus économique en capital
donc j'en parle quand même un peu pour
remplacer le charbon ou bien les 19 ans
je venais éolienne et les moyens
stockage ça leur coûtera 10 à 20 fois
plus cher en capital très bien qu'ils y
aillent
mais il faut qu'ils sachent que l'on dit
en capital ça va leur coûter 10 à 20
fois plus cher dézinguer le charbon est
une des premières priorités donc la coop
21 aurait pas parlé des deux degrés elle
aurait juste dit on est tous d'accord
pour dézinguer le charbon dans la
production électrique dans les 30 ans
qui viennent
là on aura eu un truc un peu sérieux à
se mettre sous la main c'est parce
qu'elle était décidée mais ça c'était un
truc sérieux dans l'alimentation vous
pouvez aussi des on va manger beaucoup
moins de viande de boeuf et ça c'est un
élément enfin cheptel bovin ont elles
diminué alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui
pense que j'aurais du mal aux éleveurs
pas du tout je suis favorable à un
système de quotas qui garantit donc dit
autrement
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on divise
le cheptel par deux ou trois et que on
est un système de prix minimum payé aux
éleveurs qui soit deux à trois fois est
ce qu'on leur paye aujourd'hui parce que
je les leur fait un boulot plusieurs que
moi et que à ça on rajoute des guides et
des insultes sans le paiement par la
subvention le paiement pour son boulot
de services écosystémiques comme
remettre des airs à mettre des perchoirs
les anges très utile pour bouffer les
insectes etc
donc je pense qu'on doit totalement
revoir le système d'organisation des
filières agricoles dans les pays ocde
vous avez compris que c'est le l'oeuvre
d'une vie il faut évidemment lutter
contre la déforestation il ya plein de
moyens de faire il faut s'en occuper de
manière très sérieuse et urgente ça par
exemple ça va être plus difficile d'en
supprimer le nombre afin d'en supprimer
rapidement beaucoup
par contre c'est assez facile avec des
réglementations appropriées de diminuer
leur consommation unitaire rapidement il
suffit de remettre en place une
fiscalité qui était très efficace
vignette qui était une taxe à la
détention du véhicule croissant très
rapidement en fonction de sa
consommation et d'avoir des programmes
industriels ont peut diriger
pour refaire des deux shows des temps
modernes qui concerne mon aline trede
millions de litres aux cent or s il est
simultanément vous augmenter le prix des
carburants pour que le budget transport
reste constant donc il ya des moyens de
régler sans casse sociale certains
sujets avaient déjà un peu plus de
remous d'autres on doit lutter contre
les habitudes culturelles dans cette
affaire on est des hommes nivore donc on
aime bien bouffer de la viande de temps
en temps donc le voilà mais il faut bien
comprendre et là je le redis alors alors
alors peut-être dit de manière plus soft
pour ceux d'entre vous qui n'ont écouté
mais je le redis on ne réglera pas ce
problème sans se mettre en économie de
guerre
pas au sens où il faut faire la guerre
au sens où il faut bander tous nos
muscles et conjuguer tous nos efforts en
disant c'est vraiment à nos premiers
problèmes et donc le reste ça passe
après les états unis en trois ans ont
reconfiguré un tiers de leur pays
dépendant dernier conflit mondial
donc on y arrive si on pense que
l'ennemi il est vraiment soudée tenez on
y arrive et ça s'est pas fait sans
effort
c'est sûrement pas une durée washing
pour y arriver alors il faut que j'ai
dit ça qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans
l'accord de paris on trouve un objectif
mais comme je le dis comme je vais le
montrer dans pas longtemps pas les
moyens d'y parvenir
c'est normal c'est pas le mandat des
nations unies j'ai presque fini
on trouve tout ce qui était dans
l'accord de copenhague
c'est bon c'est denis loyer qui m'a fait
remarquer sa dont la mémoire est
sûrement un doux souvenir aux personnes
de la fdj promart câble qui m'a fait
remarqué avec un air goguenard le
dernier jour de paris était en train de
siroter un café dans un gobelet consigné
et je passe à côté lui ai dit tiens t'as
vu ce truc là et il me sort accord de
copenhague
effectivement toutes les deux degrés y
sont les 100 milliards ils sont la cause
de dommages ni l or tout est lié qu'est
ce qui s'est passé entre paris et
copenhague c'est qu'à copenhague vous
avez eu un hold up du g20 sur les
nations unies c'est ça qui s'est passé
dans la nuit du jeudi au vendredi de la
deuxième semaine c'est à dire que 25
présidents se sont réunis et ont dit on
décide de ce truc on y font ce que font
des présidents dans un kopeck cela était
je pense que c'est pareil
enfin une feuille de points que si on
n'a pas d'idée on prend une feuille de
papier blanc et ont décidé
ruch donc ils ont vidé o ce truc sur une
feuille de papier et les premiers à les
commenter les douces truc devant une
caméra de télévision et gt gt à côté de
la jeune femme de l'afd de la fpjq
pardon tout et l'échangé qui a fait la
première dépêche
la première personne à commenter ça
était une jeune femme que je n'aimerais
pas du df qui a dit regarde moi c'est
avec deux pages c'est un échec et le
bruit par qui donc ce qui s'est passé à
copenhague c'est que il ya eu un coup de
gueule des ong contre le processus pas
qu'on peut résultat contre le processus
d un hold up du gène assurent les
nations unies en attendant s'il n'y
avait pas eu copenhague n'y aurait pas
eu paris parce que c'est dans copenhague
qu'on trouvait tout ce qu'ils avaient
dans paris à clarations de groupes bravo
bravo on est sauvé ouais enfin bon si à
un moment il avait pas eu les puissants
qu'avait dit on va décider silent chose
je pense qu'on y sera toujours
donc je le redis on trouve dans paris la
formalisation onusienne avec ce qui
s'appelle le lit glee binding de
copenhague
maintenant quand on regarde les chiffres
on trouve surtout la promesse d'une
hausse des émissions donc quand vous
regardez les fameuses yens décès j'adore
les acronymes onusien on passe un quart
d'heure a expliqué donc en gros ce que
l'exemple les états s'engagent à faire
et bien aujourd'hui les états s'engagent
à augmenter les émissions voilà c'est la
seule certitude de paris sachant qu'il
faut les baisser de 3% à partir de
demain
cet argent qu'on dit ouais on éviter les
5 degrés on n'est plus qu'à 2,5 d'accord
quand un de vos gamins on vous dit à
partir de demain la seule chose que je
te garantis c'est moins travailler à
l'école je sais pas si vous allez dire
ouais ça me garantit qu'il va limiter la
baisse à 8 sur 20
pas sûr vous allez avoir ça comme
raisonnement donc là la seule garantie
de paris c'est pour moment les états
s'engagent à augmenter leurs émissions
ses passions qu'ils y arriveront à cause
de ce que j'ai dit à l'heure mais c'est
la sauvegarde autre chose je me suis
amusé à faire un petit fact checking sur
ce qui s'est passé après que tout donc
j'ai regardé pour des pays qui avaient
ratifié kyoto et des pays qu'ils
n'avaient pas ratifié
si ça changeait quelque chose sur
l'évolution du contenu en co2 du clean
alors voilà une zone qui a ratifié kyoto
l'europe et vous voyez on passe de 900 à
300 grammes de co2 par dollar constant
du pipe sur la période donc division par
trois et après je prends un pays qui a
pas ratifié et on passe de 9 cents à 3
cents bon question parce que c'est un
servi à quelque chose de ratifier kyoto
réponse non est ce que pour autant ça
sert à rien d'avoir des grands maîtres
du ciel
réponse tout autant non s'affairent à
une chose c'est a déclenché un
enthousiasme mais c'est la seule chose à
laquelle ça sert
c'est la seule c'est la seule parce que
après tout les manettes sont dans les
mains des états qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour que les émissions baisse et
donc que la consommation d'énergie
fossile baisse eh bien il faut taxer
donc monté explicitement le prix qui est
un instrument très libéral soit dit en
passant qui a la main sur la fiscalité
les états il n'existe aucune entité
supranationale sauf l'europe qui est un
abandon consenti de souveraineté qui
puisse instaurer des taxes et en ce qui
concerne l'europe font l'unanimité
donc ça reste un à bordeaux on va dire
pas très violent de souveraineté ensuite
vous pouvez réglementée je décide que il
est interdit de vendre une voiture qui
concerne plus de 1 litre et demi au sens
à partir de maintenant en france qui par
les nations unies qui décide de sa race
et la france alors là il ya un vrai
avant d'une souveraineté en europe parce
que en europe c'est pas la france qui
décide c'est la commission qui décide de
ce genre de choses
aux etats unis obama a essayé de passer
par la voie réglementaire sur les
émissions par kilowattheure électrique
des centrales donc je taxe jeu
réglemente éventuellement quand les
caisses de l'état sont encore
raisonnablement plein ou que je pense
qu'elles vont leur devenir et c'est en
ce moment c'est surtout la deuxième
option
je subventions rien de tout ça n'est pas
la main des nations unies
rien rien les nations unies ont pas la
main sur le comité de bâle et dation
unis n'ont pas la main sur la
consommation par véhicule vendu en
europe et les nations unies
donc pas la main sur l'initiative qui
peut être prise par les fabricants de
vis des boulons pour diminuer de 10 %
les émissions de fabrication des vis et
boulons en se mettant d'accord sur un
cahier des charges commun sur la manière
dont ils vont acheter l'acier les
nations unies dans la main sur rien de
tout ça donc je le redis ce que peuvent
faire les nations-unies c'est créer de
l'enthousiasmé
ce que je suis pas en train de faire en
ce moment mais c'était pas ça mon mandat
je peux le faire en toute circonstance
donc c'est créer de l'enthousiasmé
mais les nations unies n'ont pas la main
les leviers concrètes qui permettent
l'action et c'est bien pour ça que ce
que je vous ai montré juste avant
correspond à une réalité ratification de
kyoto ou pas ratification de kyoto c'est
pas ça qui compte c'est ce qui va se
passer derrière
c'est ce qui va se passer derrière voilà
je vais quand même finir par un petit
clin d'oeil pour la maison qui nous
héberge un des endroits où en ce moment
il est en train de se passer des choses
qu'il faut encourager et auquel il faut
donner beaucoup plus de dynamisme que
simplement des paroles c'est ce qui est
en train de se passer dans le monde
financier d'empressement est en train de
se passer un truc rigolo c'est que
l'actionnaire est en train de se dire
qu'il ya peut-être que je pourrai dire à
la boîte dans laquelle j'investis qui a
des trucs que j'aime et les trucs que
j'aime pas c'est sûr qu'il vaut lui qui
le fasse plutôt qu'ils le fassent pas
c'est pas sa seule qui va sauver le
monde mais c'est sûr qu'il vaut mieux
voilà un petit coup d'auto promo et j'ai
fini un peu gros
on avait passé un petit peu le temps
concédé données initiales baume est à la
peine pour ceux qui peuvent rester comme
on reste ici encore quelques minutes
profitez-en pour poser des questions que
vous vous posez depuis longtemps un
agenda et connaît pas pu poser ce cas
présent il ya des micros qui vont se
balader
oui bonsoir merci pour votre
présentation furent très brillante
j'avais deux questions un exercice
intellectuel si on imagine une société
future humaine l'idéal vertueuse qui
prendrait toutes les mesures nécessaires
est ce que vous avez une idée de ce à
quoi ressemblerait cette société qu'elle
serait de la journée type du gain moyen
avec la console l'énergie disponible
pour cette personne et puis deuxième
deuxième boutique question est-ce que
vous pensez que des énergies comme les
éoliennes les panneaux photovoltaïques
ce genre de trucs peuvent exister dans
un monde sans pétrole puisque le pétrole
permis les transports l'industrie
donc est ce qu a pas un lien entre le
pétrole ne permet pas à ces énergies non
renouvelables d'exister alors la
deuxième réponse à la deuxième question
est bien sûr que oui
maintenant tout est une affaire de
quantité si vous faites un peu de
biocarburants pourrait transporter
quelques pâles d'éoliennes quand même
j'ai jamais fait les calculs précis qui
permettent de savoir combien
par contre c'est absolument certain
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la baisse du prix
des renouvelables est entre autres un
pseudopode de l'abondance des énergies
fossiles
dit autrement le jour où l'abondance des
énergies fossiles des plus là est ce que
vous avez toujours le panneau au prix
auquel il est aujourd'hui mon intime
conviction est que non puisque quand les
énergies fossiles ne sont plus là la
productivité du travail au sens où la
mesure les économistes en prend un
départ le coup dans le nez et donc le
prix de tout et de n'importe quoi
remonte donc l'idée qu' on peut
prolonger à l'infini les baisses de
coûts dans un monde qui se prive de la
base industrielle qui permet de produire
ses baisses de coûts
c'est évidemment une illusion la
première question c'est déjà oublié
si on imagine une société alors
convertis
ça c'est un exercice de romancier dit
autrement et heureusement
et heureusement parce que si tout était
écrit à l'avancé dans ce genre de monde
ce serait terriblement triste donc vous
savez ce que vous n'avez plus vous ne
savez pas ce que vous avez et
heureusement alors c'est très difficile
du coup de motiver parce que on est
quand même beaucoup plus motivés en
général par des solutions par des
problèmes c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles les politiques sont autistes
sur ce genre
sujet parce que la politique en
démocratie ils achètent une solution
envisagée est pas un problème donc pour
toujours leur expliquer qu'il faut que
tu apprennes à perdre votre temps donc
le mais est ce qu'on peut imaginer
non est-ce qu'on a quelques idées des
choses qu'il faut aujourd'hui pousser
pour éviter ce genre de problème et du
coup le genre de truc un peu concret
qu'on est déjà capable d'illustrer sa
wii ben je vous faites y vous endormir
avant d'avoir fini donc il ya eu enfin
on peut imaginer un truc mais c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle
il ya une chose qu'on peut peut-être
prévoir malheureusement c'est des
conflits ils sont déjà là
j'ai alors je voulais parfait ce soir
mais il ya une vidéo d'une conférence
que j'ai donné à physique et chimie
industrielles
il ya maintenant deux ou trois mois que
j'ai intitulé qui était juste avant la
coop que j'ai intitulé de déchets la cap
donc c'était entre comme vous pouvez
vous en douter les attentats du bataclan
et la coop 21 et vous verrez le
cheminement intellectuel que je suis
dans cette conférence pour expliquer que
ce qui se passait en syrie à un
déclencheur énergie climat majeur et du
ray ce qui s'est passé au moment des
printemps arabes a aussi lu un
déclencheur énergie climat majeur boko
haram un déclencheur climat significatif
la tuerie entre les hutus et les tutsis
si on en croit jared diamond a aussi un
déterminant alors l'occurrence
d'insuffisance agricole mais quelque
part je sais pas si les sécheresses dans
la zone avant les têtes et est juste
trop nombreux mais le mais en gros vous
avez déjà des zones dans lesquelles il
ya des conflits qui sont nées de cette
affaire là et il y en a d'autres en
préparation je peux vous donner un
endroit à mon avis ça va finir par barre
des 1 jour c'est mexique
aujourd'hui le mexique et d'exportateur
net de carburants fin de pétrole à une
population en croissance et dans une
zone de stress climatique
je sais pas où ils en sont lot de leur
autosuffisance en céréales enfin avec
une population en croissance et du
stress climatique un moment ils seront
plus et quand ils vont passer des
exportateurs importateurs de pétrole ce
qui arrivera n'importe comment entre
dans 5 à 15 ans et bien à ce moment là
ils vont se retrouver dans les veines
tonight que les syriens
se sont retrouvés en 2007 et je pense
que c'est un endroit où il va falloir
faire un peu gaffe à ses fesses
donc il ya un certain nombre de zones où
vous pouvez déjà dire que la thonaille
est en train de se refermer
et c'est absolument évident que un monde
qui va vers l'est +5 degrés il faut pas
s'imaginer ça comme comme l'a dit j'ai
plus trop quelle intellos du monde
politique français c'est un pull en
moins ou un maillot de bain en plus
forte ces devedjian pour être nommé
fellow et bien on
il faut s'attendre à un monde violent
guerrier et dont vous auront honte pour
les gens qui seront enfin je veux dire
c'est juste le sujet bonjour donc il ya
eu plusieurs scénarios
enfin de prospective énergétique sur la
table depuis cinq six ans donc deux
questions est-ce que le négawatt et un
scénario complètement utopique et
deuxième question avec les coûts de
démantèlement est ce que le nucléaire
reste bien moins cher que les prix
actuels des renouvelables
j'ai encore pas répondre aux questions
d'un bonheur sur la deuxième question le
coût constaté du démantèlement complet
d'installations nucléaires dans le monde
parce qu'un certain nombre
d'installations de centrales qui ont été
démantelées jusqu'au retour au gazon
comme on dit est de l'ordre de 15 % du
coût de construction
alors là dessus vous pouvez rajouter
plus en coûts de précaution parce que en
fait l'opération technique stricto sensu
c'est que vous arrivez avec une scie à
diamant et vous couper tout et tout ce
qui coûte cher dans la fire c'est toutes
les précautions que vous prenez parce
que vous pensez de voir les prendre dans
la succession des opérations et vous
pouvez penser que vous devez les prendre
parce que vraiment vous risquez votre
peau ou juste parce que la pression
sociale c'est qu'on vous demande de
faire comme ça alors que vous risquez
rien du tout et vous avez les deux qui
sont agrégés dans le trou du
démantèlement donc le coût technique du
démantèlement est assez faible
le coût technique du démantèlement d'une
raffinerie c'est pareil c'est 10 à 15%
bonjour rafinerie vous avez fait
saloperies vient quand vous démentez
vous avez des tas dur au carbure folie
aromatiques cancérigènes un gogo donc
voilà faut pas croire que c'est juste
les installations nucléaires qui quand
on les démantèlent pose problème
donc en jeu nos raffineries g 10 à 15%
j'ai posé la question patron de total
puisque j'étais curieux et une
installation nucléaire c'est à peu près
pareil qu'on a une quinzaine disait de
pardon de centrales en cours de
démantèlement en france toute la filière
ajoute gaz qui est en cours de
démantèlement qui a pas juste brennilis
y en a plein d'autres et il ya des
installations de recherche qui ont été
démantelés jusqu'à la fin on est
toujours un peu dans des ordres de
grandeurs qu'on connaît à peu près donc
pas obligés de multiplier sa part 2 ça
change pas fondamentalement les ordres
de grandeur le coût en capital dominant
des énergies renouvelables
intermittentes et non pilotable parce
que c'est bien celle-là dont il s'agit
dit autrement si vous avez que de
l'hydraulique
vous avez aucun problème la norvège n'a
que de l'hydraulique qu'ils ont une
électricité parfaitement compétitive
donc si vous êtes toujours dans le pilot
table dans le renouvelable
c'est une très bonne chose bon ça vous
aura quand même des kilomètres carrés le
plus grand lac de barrage au monde il
fait la taille d'un département
française complètement anodin pour le
barrage des trois gorges hal a évacué un
million de personnes s'est pas
complètement anodin donc il ya pas une
des conséquences environnementales mais
vous pouvez avoir des quantités
significatives d'électricité pilotable
avec l'hydroélectricité et en ce moment
les coûts son duvet dans puisque vous
avez pour les autres boîtes centralise
les problèmes arrivent avec quand avec
l'électricité non pilotable puisque
l'électricité en tant que tel ne se
stocke pas l'électricité est un électron
en mouvement et rétro en mouvement à
part dans les supraconducteurs ça se
trouve pas dans cet objet de transformer
godefroot de l'eau remonté en altitude
une modification de composition chimique
dans une batterie etc et le coup qui
devient dominant
si vous n'avez plus que des sources non
pilotable dans un système c'est pas le
coût de production c'est tout le reste
c'est le fait de récupérer de stocker de
renforcer le réseau parce que toute
l'électricité arrive sur des pages de
temps restreinte dont vous avez besoin
de tuyaux beaucoup plus gros pour
récupérer la même chose sur l'année le
fait que vous allez avoir des pertes de
stockage
j'entends la méta nation par exemple qui
est si chère à négawatt les pertes sont
80% 70% pas complètement anodin donc ça
veut dire que pour la partie de stocker
vous devez multiplier par 4 à 5 le parc
de production par rapport à une
consommation directe enfin donc vous
avez et ça ça commence à vous faire des
investissements absolument colossaux et
j'ai fait un calcul d'ordre de grandeur
qui montre que si au lieu d'avoir un
système tel que celui qu'on a en france
vous avez un système qui devient
entièrement basé pour la même quantité
d'électricité produite
donc c'est à ces partis le weather
produit ce que je vais vous dire qui est
basée entièrement sur des modes
intermittents non pilotable et du
stockage derrière il faut multiplier par
10 à 40
l'investissement initial comme nous
allons rentrer en décroissance je ne
pense pas qu'on va le faire
ou plus exactement si on le fait vous
aurez à l'arrivée 10 à 40 fois moins
d'électricité
donc on peut on peut le souhaiter ouais
ça me dérange pas à partir du moment où
on comprend que c'est bien ça la
contrepartie est ce que je reproche à
tous les gens qui mettent en avant un
scénario aujourd'hui c'est que en règle
générale que ce soit des gallois tous
les yeux il met toujours sous le tapis
ce truc qui ne les arrange pas parce que
comme la scénarisation n'est pas une
discipline académique aujourd'hui elle a
pas de règles normatives partagez donc
vous raconter ce qui vous a vue sur le
truc qui vous amuse et le reste sous tes
sous le tapis donc les yeux se raconte
des histoires il nous raconte des
histoires sur la disponibilité en
pétrole par exemple mais symétriquement
on était gallois tu seras content des
histoires nous raconte des histoires sur
la facilité il y à implémenter
économiquement ce qu'il propose
il ya plein de contrepartie qui sont
voilà donc cesser c'est toujours
difficile de comparer les scénarios
entre alors physiquement le scénario
négawatt possible pose pas de problème
par contre que ce soit aux niveaux
actuels de consommation d'énergie
sûrement pas et même à la moitié
je suis pas complètement sûr donc
d'avoir un mix 100 % au leader c'est
possible à une époque la france avait il
ya deux siècles le scénario de la france
était 100% aux nerfs non mais je veux
dire et puis on est là donc c'est
possible physiquement
maintenant quelles sont les
contreparties sur la manière dont on vit
ça c'est un domaine dans lequel je pense
que des gaulois est un peu court
parce que ils sont pas allés jusqu'au
bout de la logique dans les
asservissements que vous allez trouver
dans ce genre de système justement il ya
des histoires de baisse de coûts qui se
prolonge alors que vous les aurez plus
dans un monde dans lequel vous avez plus
les énergies fossiles vous allez avoir
tous les coups qui vont être multipliées
par 10 7e arr etc
donc ça c'est pas pris en compte dans
leur scénario voilà donc c'est si on se
rappelle que c'est un scénario c'est à
dire une base de discussion pour qu'on
mette les cibles sur la table et compte
cuts de bonne foi c'est très utile de
faire ce genre d'exercice mais si vous
vous baladez partout en disant c'est ça
l'avenir fait donc comme je dis ça c'est
une escroquerie
parce qu' il manque une partie de ce qui
permet de comprendre ce qu'on achète
bonjour amis la maille à castres en
parisis
j'ai une question
alors tout ce qu'on vous savez explique
effectivement c'est à l'espace à fait
imaginer ça explique très très bien en
tout ce qui pourrait se passer
par contre quand on parle du pib c'est
quelque chose supposé effectivement pbf
energy
comme vous l'avez expliqué mais quand on
regarde pib on sait que c'est un
paramètre qui est utilisé pour tous de
façon trop simplifier je suis pas
économiste je veux bien d'autres choses
mais en économie va très bien savoir
aussi toutes les les éléments comment de
l'utiliser ça comme seul paramètre pour
tout mesurer
moi je crois que c'est là dedans pour
aller au delà version 2 2 de cette
conférence de commencer à voir des
modèles futurs
au-delà de cette mode est le pb oui
parce que je crois que c'est vraiment de
changer le modèle qui va pouvoir
permettre de s'imaginer un futur pas
seulement romancier mais effectivement
de travailler sur sous tous ses
chaussons ce type de problème prenez
jamais avant alors vous avez vu que dans
la présentation j'ai commencé par la
production industrielle avant de parler
du pib donc ce que j'ai dit c'est que ce
qu'on appelle le confort matériel
c'est à dire la quantité de tables de
chaises de fourchette de mètres carrés
le voiture tout ça c'est l'industrie
répond directement la quantité d'énergie
disponible donc oublions le pib pour le
moment ce que voient les gens
aujourd'hui dans leur vraie vie c'est
que plus il ya d'énergie plus ils en
mètres carrés par personne plus c'est
facile d'acheter une voiture plus c'est
facile d'aller en voiture chez ikea
acheté chez d'autres j'ai pas d'actions
chez eux le
un set de table qui va coûter pas cher
plus c'est facile d'acheter du mouvement
puisque les objets à se déplacer
viennent de l'industrie l'avion les
voitures les camions et c'est donc en
fait c'est de plus en plus facile
d'augmenter sa consommation matérielle
et en fait quand on parle du pib c'est
ça que les gens comprennent c'est aussi
de plus en plus facile de dégager alors
le gros intérêt du pib en objectivant
legros attrait du pib pour le dirigeant
sait que pib c'est la passe fiscale
l'essentiel des prélèvements
obligatoires
aujourd'hui sont des prélèvements sur le
pib ou d'effraction du pib
quand vous regardez les prélèvements en
france toutes les charges sur les
salaires c'est une fraction du pib
l'impôt sur les sociétés c'est une
fraction du pib la tva c'est une
fraction du pib donc un monde dans
lequel le pib n'est croix est un
casse-tête pour le candidat ou vois pas
ce qu'ils doivent ou promettre que la
puissance publique va avoir moins de
moyens c'est ça qui doit vous promettre
donc ils n'aiment pas ça donc il n'a pas
envie d'entendre parler de la
décroissance du pib et fermez le ban
c'est à peu près aussi simple que ça le
donc le consommateur a pas envie
d'entendre parler de la baisse de sa
consommation et le lait lui il a pas
envie d'entendre parler de baisse de sa
base fiscale
donc c'est pour ça que tout le monde est
amoureux de la hausse du pib même si sa
mesure a parfaitement tout ce qu'on veut
et sait c'est ça la raison de fond pour
laquelle on a envie que ça monte c'est
pas parce que les gens ont bien compris
ce que c'était et qu' ils ont un amour
académique pour le pib c'est juste parce
que la compréhension qu'ils ont annoncé
que plus de pib égale plus de
consommation accessoirement plus
d'emplois et accessoirement moins de
problèmes budgétaires c'est ça qu'ils
ont compris alors moi je pense que
malheureux oui sauf que nous on est en
ce moment la dcsp plus confortablement
assis au chaud
cet après midi on avait les ateliers du
shift dans un centre d'hébergement
d'urgence pas complètement persuadés que
la femme qui est en hébergement
d'urgence avec son gamin là on était cet
après midi si on lui dit tu vas encore
baisser la consommation elles soient
d'accord
donc oui il faut changer
je suis d'accord du reste c'est plus
facile pour vous et moi
mais il faut bien comprendre que les
implications je le redis suppose une
modification de notre rapport au monde
qui est très importante et en
particulier ça suppose qu'on ait bien
compris qu'en ce moment on est en train
de jouer à un jeu où l'addition finale
vraisemblablement ne vaudra pas la peine
d'avoir joué à ce jeu là mais on le
comprend pas rentrez chez vous ce soir
est allumé le 20 heures de tf1 vous
comprendrez parce que je verrai pas la
trace de ce que je viens de vous
raconter acheter un journal demain matin
vous ne verrez pas la trace de ce que je
viens de raconter écouter les
conversations des gens dans le métro
quand vous rentrerez chez vous vous ne
verrez pas la trace de ce que je raconte
est donc aujourd'hui le problème il est
vu comme étant très distant très
extérieur non encore présents et c est
donc les gens se disent moi je veux un
job et je veux pouvoir aller chez ikea
qu'est-ce qu'on emmerde avec ce genre de
trucs et la pédagogie du problème ça
c'est le drame des démocraties est
extrêmement difficile à faire à lorient
prendre une dernière question oui
bonsoir espionnage et juste simplement
je te font simplement faire écho vous
avez parlé d'un cours de démantèlement
et sert à des centrales et une de vos
solutions
est-ce que vous avez un scénario sur
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre
s'entraînerait le démantèlement c'est de
l'ordre de 20 grammes par kilowattheure
en gros le nucléaire c'est 10 g par
kilowattheure avec la concentration
actuelle d'uranium dans le minerai est
le premier déterminant de l'émission par
kilowattheure c'est la teneur en
concentration dans le minerai parce que
pour aller chercher de minerais du
diesel donc c'est à ce moment vous
émettez du co2 vous n'allez pas le
chercher avec de l'électricité nucléaire
celui là après vous avez une phase
d'enrichissement qu elle vous pouvez
faire l'électricité nucléaire donc ça ne
met pas beaucoup il faut construire la
centrale
ça fout couler du béton de l'acier mais
les émissions de construction pour ça
pour un engin qui va cracher des
quantités faramineuses de kilowattheures
sur sa vie rapporté
à l'arrivée ces quelques grammes donc
c'est là c'est du même ordre de grandeur
soit dit en passant pour les barrages
les barrages vous allez aussi être dans
cet ordre de grandeur 10 g par par
kilowattheure sont si vous allez mettre
un petit saut que vous ne voyez la
biomasse à ce moment vous êtes à 306
noms sinon vous êtes aussi dans les
mêmes les méandres des vendeurs
prévoient la toute dernière question mon
sac pour en revenir au sujet des guerres
est ce que le steak le sujet des
réfugiés climatiques a été évoquée
pendant la coop 21 et comment at il été
traités quand vous regardez la question
des réfugiés climatiques dans la presse
ou les voyants général lié à la montée
des eaux
c'est le grand sujet sur les réfugiés
climatiques
personne aujourd'hui ne songe à
qualifier les réfugiés syriens de
réfugiés climatiques
à part peut-être mois pour une partie
c'est clair que s'il n'y avait pas eu
assad avait pas eu et caetera et quand
on n'avait pas créé il ya un siècle des
pays en mettant dans le même endroit les
sunnites les chiites et tout le reste on
n'aurait peut-être pas le même problème
mais cela étant ça vous avez déjà la
trace du pétrole
c'est un tous les pays du moyen-orient
sont des créations des puissances
coloniales on s'est partagé le pétrole
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
fait des frontières tout droite avec le
pétrole à toi d'un côté le pétrole à
droite de l'autre puis s'il ya des
chiites et les sunnites au dessus du
pétrole on s'en fout c'est vraiment pas
le problème donc une des raisons pour
lesquelles aujourd'hui vous avez des
problèmes ça vient du pétrole mais il ya
un siècle
et puis une deuxième raison pour
laquelle vous avez des problèmes c'est
que vous avez la conjonction d'un stress
économique venant de dévots de pétrole
dans le monde
et lun 13 climatique venant des
sécheresses dans le bassin méditerranéen
qui s'est mis alors à peu près de
manière coordonnée et ça vous a fait
exploser le couvercle de la marmite
personne je le redis ne songe à
qualifier les réfugiés syriens de
réfugiés climatiques
pourtant ils en sont quelque part donc
les réfugiés climatiques tout le monde
s'imagine que c'est les habitants du
bangladesh qui vont nous envahir ça ne
va jamais arrivé ça ou alors quelques
très riche les autres ils iront envahir
l'inde le pakistan
voilà et vous allez en avoir des
mouvements de population de manière
croissante au gré des stress
alimentaires et des stress économique
ils vont être là les réfugiés
climatiques
ils vont pas tellement être dans les
gens qui déménagent année après année
parce qu'au niveau de la mer monte pas
comme ça que ça va se passer
ils y apprennent de dame nature du coup
qu'est ce que vous mettez dedans comment
vous arrivez à les compter en général
vous fait pas dans les déclarations
douanières au poste de douane être voix
réfugiés climatiques
cochez la case oui non donc vous avez un
prime pour les compter mais par contre
pour les qualifiés que je vous dise et
quand vous regardez un peu ce genre de
trucs
la fourchette est large le fait de ne
pas les voir comme tel soit dit en
passant
contribuer à ce que j ai tout à l'heure
c'est à dire à penser que le problème de
temps en temps pendant très longtemps
malheureusement on va être obligé de
s'arrêter là merci beaucoup je meurs
la prochaine séance dont j'ai pas
d'attenté le 12 avril nous aurons
notamment olivia l'âge qui avait créé
avec ball qui viendront nous exposer
leur point de vue sur le pétrole et en
particulier pourquoi le prix du baril
est si bas c'est bas aujourd'hui voilà
ainsi à des tops